What's up everybody!
We are Pongfinity
And today we are taking table tennis to the
sunny streets of Helsinki.
We'll be challenging strangers to a game of
table tennis
With these 3 items.
They will get to choose which one we will
play with.
If they manage to beat us
We will give them 20 euros.
Let's go!
Well, that was not an easy match
but luckily I won.
Thanks man.
Yeah, no problem!
Thank you, thank you.
We need a picture!
Have a good one!
You too!
So, unfortunately our first loss.
The wind wasn't on our side and...
the plate wasn't quite my strength...
Yea yea, excuses excuses!
Alright, today
we found one guy who was able to beat Miikka
with a plate.
Congratulations to him!
We had a lot of fun filming this episode
If you enjoyed it too, remember to leave it
a thumbs up
And subscribe to our channel.
Until next time!